the historic town of guildford in surrey
known for its cobbled streets high-end
shops and famous guildhall clock
but even this affluent high street isn't
immune to the pressures of the pandemic
the harem beauty bar has been a staple
here for 21 years
but forced to shut its doors for the
third time in the last 12 months
owner gemma is desperate for rishi sunak
to switch on more support
in next week's budget i had a good
successful business
um that gave me a nice lifestyle
and i wasn't in any debt and i'd say
now probably at least 35 000 pounds
i owe um in rent um which is obviously
not a nice place to be when you're not
used to being in debt
and i'm a personal guarantor of my lease
which means that
you know if the landlords decide to
pursue me
it could be my house that could go huge
amounts of
stress worry about the future
i do have two young children that i
support
and actually wondering whether or not
it's worth continuing in this industry
because realistically to pay the debt
back
we'd need to up our takings by about 20
a month
and obviously we guarantee that we can
open for the foreseeable future as well
um which is quite unrealistic
hairdressers and other non-essential
retail will be allowed to open their
doors again on april the 12th
but for gemma that's just the start of
the fight back
she's also worried about the future of
guildford high street
there are so fewer shops now retail
shops
um there's not an awful lot to come to
the high street for
which i guess is the rents are just too
high
and people can't make it work this week
rishi sunak will announce a new 5
billion pound grant scheme to help shops
pubs gyms and hair salons like gemmas
all hit hard by the pandemic without
government help like this
the ippr think tank believes almost 600
000 companies are at risk of collapsing
this spring
we reckon that some 40 percent of of the
smallest businesses which are actually
really vulnerable so employ
less than 50 people um have something in
the region of less than three months
cash um to keep themselves going uh
and many of those businesses will be on
the high street
um so it's a really a really serious
situation there or potentially a bit of
a ticking time bomb
um for the economy and many lives and
livelihoods depending on on whether
those
those businesses will make it do you
think that
once things get better the high street
will ever fully recover
well i think we know from the research
that we have done that even before the
crisis
the high streets were under pressure and
and many time centers were feeling the
the impact of online shopping but also
changes in the way that we use town
centers
um and i think that um for for many
time centers the crisis has accelerated
these trends further
um and moved us to our position much
faster than perhaps we would have done
otherwise the other challenge for for
high streets and for town centres across
the uk is around business rates and we
know that
the uk's land and property um
tax system is really inefficient since
rishi sunak delivered
his first budget a year ago we've seen
the biggest hit to gdp since records
began
a national debt rise to more than two
trillion pounds
for the chancellor the pressure is on to
chart a path to recovery
i think we have got some tax rises
coming down the line but i don't think
we're going to get big tax rises this
time
around there's so much uncertainty about
what's going to happen to the economy
over the next year
there's so much uncertainty actually how
much tax we're going
to need in the medium term and
the focus of the movement i think is
getting the economy back on its
feet what i'd like to hear from the
chance there is a commitment though
to getting that fiscal balance in the
medium
run so i don't really want him to say
i'm going to be raising taxes a lot this
year
but i do want him to be saying that if
in a couple of years we've still got a
very big deficit which is
adding to the overall debt then he will
do something about it and
be clear that he is willing to raise
taxes if that's what's needed
we've had the road not now you've been
mentioning the date in june when it
feels that the restrictions are going to
be
lifting at least most of the
restrictions the government's always
said that that will be data
driven but it seems like they're saying
that it will only be slowed down if the
data
isn't as good as expected do you think
it should also be sped up if the data is
better
than thought i think it's very clear
that if we
um if things move more quickly more
positively than expected if we have
uh a very high fraction of people
vaccinated and very low levels
um of infection then then yes it should
be
sped up there's no need to stick to a
date
if things go better than expected and
every
month every week of additional uh
lockdown is costing not just the economy
i mean
it's costing so many people so much in
terms of their
mental health their education their work
and everything else that
um it should be moved as quickly as is
possible
uh consistent uh with um doing it safely
and so if we can do it quicker we
absolutely should
throughout the crisis rishi sunak has
enjoyed positive approval ratings but
it's easy to be popular
when you're dishing out money at some
point the recovery process and the
fiscal rebalancing
will have to begin the question is is
now the time
pajama the answer is no without more
government intervention she worries her
business won't survive
please cut about five percent keep
business rates at zero for the
foreseeable future
and to intervene with our private
landlords and our insurers
this hairdressers will open its doors
again on april the 12th along with other
non-essential retail
but it's what happens next week that
will determine whether many businesses
like this one
shut up shop for good